what else happened Nick let's get into
Sanders oh wait I'll even play this what
was this clip somebody sent me this is
Krista Lee and Bobby what is this net
yeah this is from recent tiger belly it
was on January 3rd Chris joint Bobby the
Bobby Lee Bobby Lee Bobby Leon and I'll
tell you this about Bobby Lee and I've
said this to Bobby Lee before Bobby
Lee's probably one of the top 70 or 80
Asian people and I'm told by B if he
didn't keep his [ __ ] together I will
take him on a tour of VFW's around the
country and watch old men beat his ass
brother and you know this go on Nick
yeah Chris joined Tiger belly podcast
and kind of out of nowhere your name
came up okay let's take let's hear that
clip something else to you and I wait
I'm gonna look in your eyes okay
and that's Bobby he sounds like a cat
with like a little bit of emphysema not
that there is one but if there was a
room or the time he was a yovan yeah if
there was ever a war sure you you have
my assurance this is a slap Kingdom
mm-hmm Mike and they call him a slap
Kingdom cuz he sleeps 21 hours a day and
obviously taking advantage of his
freedom here in America let's hear more
that people the papayas you're the king
of the north
that's very cool you're the king of the
north yeah the King in the north could
it land in st. Louis absolutely
unbelievable king of the north can't
even get to the Midwest and my clan my
my people clan did you hear that I don't
use that kind of terminology Yeah right
I love them as a Rat King
the guy who gets his dick cut off in the
and that's where they all laugh at
someone else that's not in the room
pretty crazy man
it's just tough you know it's it's it's
shit's getting real in these podcast
streets and I'll say this Bobby
whenever you pass away of some you know
disease because you obviously have
something if I sleep in 23 hours a day
throw after that you're asleep 24 hours
a day that's dead minutes away from
needing someone to take care of your
beautiful girlfriend brother and don't
you worry about it I will make sure that
I know you've been making sure she stays
asleep I'll make sure she stays awake
brother love you guys man well thanks
for watching that big deal
Wow Wow he doesn't know he doesn't know
that what we're doing is for funsies
yeah he wants to start a real war okay
and first of all I don't sleep 23 hours
a day not that much right 20 min of 1920
you know he's a cute guy you know but
he's gonna go wrong you know war let me
see something you know or you know that
tiger not fight on the cot kids yeah was
it then Brendan yeah I the type of a
fighter the kid in calendar daliyah this
guy do you all go to war and at the end
of the day I'm a Targaryen dude and I
that's not my rightful throne you know
that [ __ ] right Targaryen Targaryen flat
flat yeah this country [ __ ] though I
like them dude don't you yeah he's
alright right damn yeah and that's all
that's why you're a part of my kingdom
did cuz your heart is in the right place
they love you did I love you I love you
too man okay you too right